I thought it was gonna be a blood test
and they would call us in a week or
something that was too fast huh
I was just like part of too much
information too fast
well what do we do I think we should
keep it [ __ ] we should keep it you don't
I didn't say that look I don't I
honestly don't know I've never thought
of this before
honestly I kind of thought that like my
genetic line should end with me I'm not
helping anyone I honestly thought I
smoked so much pot I was sterile yes not
I mean just keep in mind that good that
little harpy that will flicker we saw on
screen that's weak part your heartbeat
maybe if it wasn't on TV it's right
there you know it's the way you know
it's your call whichever whatever you
want to do you didn't cry when you saw
the egg so there's weird I mean well
it's weird that you look at this huge
monumental moment and not feeling
anything just kind of stare like a robot
a robot well I'm sorry if I didn't react
how you expected me to some people cry
some people don't I'll cry later and
I'll call you hey I mean seriously all I
saw was a pixelated dot you know that
makes you cry don't blame me for not
crying maybe we should just not talk
maybe you know it's not a good call
Hey what okay I sent out I said I'll do
what you want to do such a mess hey we'd
never have done this
never has this job but I don't have any
money and I live with my sister in her
guest house and they don't know you
[Music]
I'm sorry mr. zazic maybe we gonna be
like every mood swings because mom I
don't I don't think this is a mood swing
yes this is a legitimate mood if I was
normal
I'd be crying too I have problems it's
okay you know
you should be crying want to go out on a
date with me I know that sounds very
very bitter even just saying it but you
know I mean we are with child and if you
know if we're gonna do this but maybe we
should get to know each other at least a
little yeah editor Oh the greevey I saw
a man put a transducer inside you so I
know you a little
I know what your cervix looks like hey
yeah looks like that yeah we'll just go
for dinner or something
yeah I would love to go out on a date
with you if we go somewhere really
expensive I'll cry yeah can we get out
of here yeah are you part too late yeah
the parking garage we walked together I
don't really remember my levels oh oh oh
look for it was okay